>>Male Presenter: Welcome everybody to another
Authors@Google talk. Today we have as our
guest at Google, Professor David Deamer, from
the Department of Biomolecular Engineering
at the University of California. He's going
to talk about the evolution of very early
life and his book, which just came out in
print, is called "First Life." So, please
welcome David Deamer. Thank you.
[applause]
>>David Deamer: Well, thank you all for coming.
It is really a treat and a pleasure. I gave
a Tech Talk here last year. But my pleasure
here today is reading my first love, which
is how did life begin and how did life begin
to evolve. So, we're making a lot of progress.
And you're gonna hear about that today. You're
also gonna hear a little bit of history about
how my own research career got started and
how its progressed through the last about
30 years, believe it or not, and how it finally
culminated in this little book that came out
earlier this month.
So, this is an Author's Talk and we're supposed
to do little readings out of our book. But
that's boring just to hear readings. I'm gonna
do a couple of short paragraphs here and there
to illustrate as we go on. So, "First Life."
That is the book company's USC Ppress title.
I thought it was pretty good. We played with
a lot of titles and that was the one that
really came out. I later discovered that this
was also of David Attenborough's television
series. So, that's just the luck of the draw.
So, "First Life" and what you're gonna hear
about from me today is that life, at least
at its beginning and still today, depends
on what is called self-assembly processes.
Now what you're seeing up there in that little
image to the right is a bit of dried phospholipid.
And when phospholipid interacts with water,
it self-assembles into membranous structures.
So as part of my talk, I'm gonna take you
back 40 years in time to the person who discovered
this and how I spent some time with him and
began to work on this project.
So, it's not just this book that came out,
which is a lay-person's version. It's readable,
I hope. There's also technical version that
came out last year. Jack Szostak and I got
together with the Cool Springs Harbor Press.
And this is 20 chapters from a variety of
authors, including Jack and myself, giving
a very up-to-date vision of how life could
have begun right from the start in fact, as
Earth became a planet.
So, those are the things that have, that you're
gonna hear a bit about today. And I'm gonna
start by reminding you of this saying. Most
of you know the acronym. It's "keep it simple,
stupid." Leaving out the stupid, this is what
we tell our students in our laboratories.
Keep it simple. And what that means is it
comes out of a reductionistic philosophy that
scientists use to try to, literally, keep
it simple, to keep things under control. But
I have another little acronym that I pass
along after I get that across. B-N-T-S. And
that stands for: But not that simple.
[laughter]
Because we have been limited. We are limiting
ourselves when we think about the origin of
life by doing little baby steps. You know,
this molecule, that molecule. How do they
link together to make a little dimer of some
sorts?
So these are baby steps. I think the point
of my book is let's look at a bigger picture
and try to get something sufficiently complex.
Well, sufficiently complex. What do I mean
by that? Some of you may recognize Stanley
Miller's experiment that was published about
1953, however many years ago that is--half
a century--to round off.
And what Stanley did was to put together a
sufficiently complex simulation of the early
Earth. And this is how we learn about the
origin of life. We try to simulate something
in the laboratory, keeping it simple, and
try to learn from a simulation that tests
a hypothesis.
So, Stanley's hypothesis was that if you had
four gases--water, ammonia, methane, and ammonia--those
four gases, the four biogenic before biotrenic
elements, and if you put in some energy as
a spark, an electrical discharge there, that
that would be sufficiently complex to make
something interesting.
Those are the four molecules, very simple
gas molecules, including boiling water down
there in the bottom left. And he then sparked
it for a day and for a week. And he had this
spark discharge going and it began to turn
a light-yellow color, and then an orange color,
and then a red color, and then a brownish
color about a week later.
And the sides of the flask became coated with
a product of this reaction. Amazingly, there
were hundreds of products produced from this
simple reaction, including amino acids. And
that's what caught people's eyes because amino
acids are the monomers of all life on the
Earth.
They're used to make proteins. Smaller proteins
are called peptides. And the bond that holds
them together is called the peptide bond,
which is one of the--.the things that wWe
have to figure out how that came to be. So,
that really caught people's attention. And
it started the field up.
Now let's see what I mean by "insufficiently
complex." Suppose that Stanley thoughtlessly
left out one of those molecules. Nothing would
have happened. The simulation would have been
insufficiently complex. And so, in our laboratories
today, we're trying to learn how to make our
simulations sufficiently complex.
And that's what you're gonna hear about today.
And you're gonna hear about some results from
this step toward the end of my talk today.
Well, the concepts I put together in "First
Life" to produce something that I feel is
sufficiently complex are as follows:
Conditions.
I feel that there must have been compartments.
And that, really, is a fairly new concept.
People did not think about life as beginning
as cells. People thought of life as beginning
as molecules. But my claim is that we really
needed a cellular compartment to keep everything
together in one place.
There must have been a way to concentrate
the organic molecules that are gonna react.
And they must be cycled. That's another thing
we don't think about when we do these simulations.
We just turn on the spark and wait to see
what happens, or we add a couple of reactants
and wait and see what happens.
That's the chemist's way of doing things.
But there is another process, which I'm sure
some of you have heard about called the polymerase
chain reaction- P-C-R. It depends on cycles.
You put in a little bit of DNA. You cycle
it through a hot-cold cycle. A little bit
more DNA is produced. Another hot-cold cycle.
Forty or fifty cycles and you have millions
of times more DNA than you started with. This
is a central process that is used in all molecular
biology laboratories today, discovered about
maybe 30 years ago now. So, keep in mind cycles.
I think the cycles are important.
There must have been a fluctuating environment.
The components we're talking about, of course,
there must have been a source of organic compounds.
The first part of my talk I'm gonna tell you
about one possible source, which is an extraterrestrial
source.
We think that a lot of the organics were brought
to the Earth, available for the oceanorigin
alikeof life, were delivered here in the late
accretion of our planet. And you're gonna
hear about that. Then there had to be a source
of energy. You can't get reactions to go unless
you go from uphill to downhill.
There has to be a source of energy to get
the reactants uphill. Only then, can they
react and go downhill toward equilibrium and
make something interesting. So we have to
think about what energy source was available
on the early Earth to drive these reactions.
Finally, sufficient complexity. That's gonna
involve self-assembly of these molecules.
And I'm gonna demonstrate this to you. It
involves an organizing matrix. Now, this is
a relatively new idea, by the way. We have
thought that probably clay might have been
involved.
The surface of clay can organize molecules
and allow certain polymerization reactions
to occur. But I'm gonna tell you about a different
organizing matrix that we are working on.
As a result of all this, you get what I call
"combinatorial chemistry."
Each of these compartments is a microscopic
test tube and each compartment is different
from all the others. It's a combination of
molecules in those individual compartments.
And I'm talking about vast numbers of compartments
that would've been around on the early Earth.
A few of these--a very few of these--likely
had a set of molecules that, by chance, could
grow by polymerization. They could capture
energy and nutrients from the environment
and undergo polymerization. Furthermore, not
only grow, but they can reproduce by some
process.
And right at the end of my talk, you're gonna
hear about a way to produce long nucleic acid
strands and get them to reproduce under simulated
prebiotic conditions. So that's where I'm
going in this talk. OK. Now I wanna talk a
little bit about how we got started in all
of this. And that comes to my first reading.
There's only two of these, so don't worry.
[laughter]
[reads from book]
"During the spring and summer of 1975, I was
spending a sabbatical leave with Alec Bangham
in his Babraham laboratory just south of Cambridge,
England, when an idea emerged that guided
me into research on the origin of life.
“ A few years earlier, Alec had discovered
the self-assembly properties of phospholipid
and showed that lecithin extracted from egg
yolks could produce microscopic vesicles,
ultimately forming structures that we now
call liposomes.
“One summer day, Alec and I were driving
to London in his beloved Morris Mini, we pulled
over to the side of the road to enjoy some
cucumber sandwiches--I'll never forget that--prepared
by Rosalyn Bangham, that's Alec's wife. Now
the conversation turned to a lecture that
Alec had given a few years earlier at Bristol
University with the title, ‘Membranes Came
First.’
“Alec argued that the self-assembly properties
of lipids were such that the membrane's vesicles
must have been present on the early Earth,
long before nucleic acids and proteins came
along. But then we were stumped. What was
the prebiotic equivalent of lipids that can
self-assemble into membranes and where did
they come from?"
[ends reading]
Well, here is Alec's image. This is from 1971.
He let me take a picture of this. And back
in the old days, before PowerPoint and Keynote
and video projectors, if you were giving a
scientific talk--I'm sure you won't believe
this--you had to make a drawing of what you
wanted to talk about, take a picture, and
make a slide of that.
That's the way it used to be done. These days,
of course, we left that far behind. But I
still remember the thrill I have when I gave
my very first computer-aided talk like this.
It makes things so much easier. In any event,
notice that Alec has the Earth and a very
thick ocean.
He shows evolution going around in a cycle.
He shows sodium and potassium ions in the
ocean. And he shows a monolayer. Look right
down there at the bottom. And you can see
a lot of little squiggly tails. Those are
hydrocarbons. The head group is hydrophilic--
water-loving-- so it sticks down into the
water, dissolves in the water.
But the tail cannot dissolve. Oil and water
don't mix. So this is a monolayer. Then, he
said, if you have some sort of aerodynamic
perturbation protovation, just wind, tides,
waves in action, and so forth, that those
monolayers would crimp inward and turn into
liposomes.
So that is his idea about why membranes could
come first. And really, from that moment on,
I've been testing that idea. I'd like to show
you Alec Bangham. This is a picture I took
about seven or eight years ago. And there
you see him making self-assembled amphiphilic
membranes in his backyard.
Those, by the way, are called soap bubbles
in common language. And really, a soap bubble
is a membrane. It's a self-assembled membrane.
I would guess everybody in this room at one
time in your life has blown some bubbles like
Alec is doing up there.
What I'm gonna do now though, is to show you
what Alec saw under the microscope when he
first discovered the self-assembly property
of phospholipid.
[jazz piano music plays]
He did not have the jazz piano background,
by the way. That's what it looks like. I do
this work in my lab. Watch the lipid reacting
with water to produce these beautiful self-assembled
structures.
Our claim is that something like upward of
[jazz music continues over voice ]. This is
what Alec saw in the electron microscope.
This is just one accident, by the way. He
wanted to test out their new microscope and
he had these interesting self-assembled structures.
So he put that under the microscope and added
what's called a negative stain that lets him
see, literally, the single-molecule level.
And he saw not just globs, but he saw those
layers. You can probably count ten or twenty
layers in that structure. This is a multilamellar
phospholipid structure.
And he called these, in his paper, multilamellar
phospholipid mesophases, which is a bit of
a mouthful. So, people began calling them
Banghasomes in his honor. And GJerry Weissmann,
an early visitor to his lab before I got there,
invented this word: liposomes.
You may have heard of liposomes because their
properties were not lost on the cosmetic industry.
Christian Dior captured liposomes without
telling Alec, by the way. Alec learned about
this because his wife, Rosalyn, received an
ad like this in the mail, saying that they
had this cosmetic called "Capture XR60/80
Bi-Skin Extra-Vital Skin Restoring Serum."
And look there. Powerful liposome system.
So this is now used to deliver cosmetic materials
to skin surfaces-- anti-wrinkles and all that
stuff. It's also used in the drug industry.
There are anti-tumor agents that are captured
in liposomes, injected into the bloodstream,
carried to the tumor cell, and produce death
of the tumor cell.
So, liposomes are very powerful, far beyond
what I'm telling you about today with the
origin of life. I have always been amused
by that little story. Well, that brings me
to the next little reading--my last one.
[reads from book]
"In the summer of 1981, a small, black stone
wrapped in aluminum foil changed the course
of my life. About the size of a marble and
indistinguishable from any other rock that
might be found on a beach, this stone had
traveledtravelled from southeastern Australia
to the NASA Ames Research Center in Mountain
View, California."
Literally just down the street from here.
"Where researcher Sherwood Chang showed me
the specimen and gave me a small sample. But
the stone had traveledtravelled even further.
It was a piece of a meteor that lit up the
night sky over the town of Murchison, Australia
in September 1969.
“ The fall began with a bright orange fireball,
rolling thunder followed minutes later by
a shower of black stone, strewn over five
square miles. I held in my hand a genuine
rock from outer space. But there was more
to this meteorite than just the mineral content,
typical of other stony meteorites.
“ The first stones to be discovered just
hours after they fell were still emitting
a smoky aroma from their hot surfaces. And
the first time I ground up a marble-sized
sample of the meteorite, this strange, penetrating
odor rose from the mortar, simultaneously
smoky, dusty, and sour, reminiscent of a cigar
butt, or the contents of a vacuum cleaner
bag.
“It was this sticky smell that I would now
recognize anywhere. It was the odor of outer
space, nearly five billion years old--the
aroma of organic compounds that were delivered
directly to the Earth during the birth of
our solar system. Nothing could be more convincing
at the link between organic processes and
life on the Earth."
So, this is NASA Ames as it looks today. There's
a nice name given over to the building that
Sherwood worked in, that I worked in. The
Astrobiology and Life Sciences Laboratory.
My first visit in 1981. And this is what Sherwood
looked like back then, as a young man. He's
now retired. He's got his own ranch up in
far Northern California. And this is the kind
of thing that he gave to me, not this particular
piece. Just a piece I got later, but he gave
me a little chunk, not that big to work with.
So, I'm a lipid-biophysicist. And I was still
trying to think of a way to test that question
that Alec and I thought about. What were the
first kinds of lipids? So, if you're a lipid
person, you use an organic solvent to extract
what you're interested in. And nobody had
tried this before.
So I treated a chunk of that Murchison with
chloroform and methanol and you're gonna hear
about that as soon as I tell you just a bit
about where it came from. So, one source of
organic compounds on the early Earth is delivery
during late accretion. So this is the asteroid
Eros.
And it's from a NASA JPL slide-by in the last
few years. Look at the impact craters. Those
are on every asteroid we've looked at. Those
impact craters occur when a smaller chunk
of stone hits the larger chunk. And we've
actually seen that happen just by chance.
This image was captured when people were looking
at the asteroid belt. And they saw what looked
at first like a comet, but it wasn't. It turns
out that that tail coming out, that little
white speck there, you can see in the enlarged
in-set, was in fact, potential meteorites.
Any of those chunks that happened to hit the
Earth would have been a meteorite. And this
is how the Murchison meteorite got here. So
we're seeing, with carbonaceous meteorites,
samples of extraterrestrial material that
probably came about the same time as the Earth.
And it's been delivering organic compounds
to the Earth ever since and so, as you saw
in that Murchison meteorite. This is what
it would look like if you happened to look
up in the sky. This is just a Photoshop version
that I put together for illustrating purposes,
but there was an explosion up there.
And the pieces fell to Earth in the little
town of Murchison, Australia. This is a real
image of the town of Murchison that you can
see in the upper left corner. And each of
those red spots represents a place where pieces
of Murchison, maybe about this size to this
size, were picked up along with hundreds of
smaller pieces.
Those are the ones that I've worked with.
So those are in museums all over the world.
They've been worked on extensively by the
community with an interest in this. And we
know more about the Murchison than any other
meteorite so far. So, this is why they're
so interesting.
If you analyze the Murchison, you discover
it's around two percent organic material by
weight, most of which is a polymer called
kerogen, or kerogen-like polymer. But some
of them are soluble--that little red pie slip
there. And then of the soluble, you can see
that some of them are carboxylic acids.
There are dicarboxylic acids, amino acids,
amides, aliphatic hydrocarbons, aromatic hydrocarbons,
aldehydes, alcohols, amines, and even purines.
You know that amino acids are what we use
as monomers for proteins. Purines, like adenine,
are used in nucleic acids.
So here is literally all, or most, of the
stuff we would want to have available if we're
gonna think about how life could begin. What
I want to call attention to is the carboxylic
acids, which are about half of the mass of
the organics. And one of them that you're
gonna see is a membrane-forming compound,
because that's what we discovered.
And here it is. So, I extracted a chunk of
the Murchison, maybe a gram sample, put it
into a mixture of chloroform and methanol,
ground it up, took the sample and put it under
a microscope and let the chloroform dry. And
then you add water, which is the way you watch
self-assembly, and this is what I saw. Really
quite extraordinary.
This stuff has never been alive, never part
of a life process, but it still could self-assemble
into membranous vesicles. And we propose that
these are the kinds of compartments that would
have been available on the early Earth for
the first living cells to take advantage of
as a house to live in, as they did the rest
of what life is all about.
So here's a phase image of some of the vesicles.
We captured some fluorescent dye in it. That's
what you see over on the right-hand side there,
just to demonstrate that these are actually
compartments that can contain something.
And what you're going to hear a little bit
later is that these compartments have some
very special properties helping polymerization
to occur. Well, what are those membrane components?
One last trip to Stanford and we took some
of that sample to Dick Zeder'sZare's lab.
He's got a beautiful mass spectrometer to
work with. And he sent me back this image
which shows that what that stuff is, is octanoic
acid, nonanoic acid, decanoic acid, and all
the way up to 13 carbons long. This is what
those things look like, by the way.
In a membrane, you have a hydrocarbon tail--the
black and white--and you have the hydrophilic
head group. This is nothing but soap. You
wash your hands with this. It cleans it off.
This is a soap molecule. So, we had found
soap molecules in the Murchison meteorite
and discovered that they could self-assemble
into those membrane structures that I showed
you there.
Really quite extraordinary. So there's what
those things look like. They've been stained
with a fluorescent dye. That's just decanoic
acid. That's this stuff, just to prove that
it can form membranes. Well, before I go to
the next step, I'm gonna do a little demonstration
for you just to nail down in your minds how
simple the formation of membranes encapsulating
stuff is.
So I used to be a teenage magician and this
is as close as I get these days to doing a
little bit of magic. Here's just a buffer
solution--water plus a little bit of buffer
in it. Here's a nucleic acid. This particular
one is ribonucleic acid, but I could use deoxyribonucleic
acid as well--DNA.
So, I'm gonna put a few milligrams in here.
It dissolves right away. This is water soluble.
And the question is how could something like
this, even if it got synthesized by some process
on the early Earth, how could it get into
these vesicles I showed you, because vesicles
are relatively impermeable to make molecules?
There must be a mechanism. And if you just
do nothing more than dry down your lipid,
mix in your solution, and shake it up, what
you discover is that you have self-assembled
lipid vesicles. That's that cloudiness you
see there. And the lipid vesicles have encapsulated
the RNA.
It's as simple as that to make what we call
protocells. These are steps toward the origin
of life--biggish molecules with potential
catalytic replicating ability trapped inside
lipid vesicles. So, that's how simple it is.
So we're not saying anything outlandish when
I claim that it's easy to do and easy to conceive
of.
Now we're actually trying to see whether that
does any good with respect to the origin of
a replicating catalytic system. Well, I wanted
to take you one more step in the history of
this. I visited NASA Ames again in the early
1990s. And by this time we had shown that
the meteorite membranes could be produced
from the Murchison components.
And Lou Allamandola was an astrochemist. He's
still active at NASA Ames. And Jason Dwoarkin
had just finished his Ph. D.Ph.D. with Stanley
Miller and wanted to do his post-doctoral
work in the astrochemistry laboratory with
Lou. So, we decided to see whether this stuff
that Lou was synthesizing as a simulation
of what goes on in what is called pre-cometary
ice.
And you're gonna understand that. I gotta
show you a few more things before you understand
it completely. But what he does is cool a
chamber, a vacuum chamber, down to liquid
helium temperatures and then he injects gases
into the chamber, including water, methanol,
carbon monoxide, and ammonia.
And a thin layer of ice forms on that ultra-cold
surface. Then he bombards that surface with
ultraviolet radiation and this is what happens
in what we call molecular clouds. Our Earth,
our solar system and stars, are all born in
dense molecular clouds, light years in dimensions.
And you're gonna see a little bit more about
that momentarily. And as this occurs, that
ice with the UV impinging on it can make big
molecules. And here's what we then published
after a couple of years of work. "Self-assembling
amphiphilic molecules: Synthesis of simulated
interstellar/pre-cometaryprecometary ices."
So the answer to where the stuff in the Murchison
came from is it was, a lot of it anyway, was
synthesized on the surface of these little
dust particles that I'm gonna show you in
just a minute. So this is the kind of image
that we saw, starting with nothing more than
water, methanol, carbon monoxide, ammonia.
And when you hit this with UV radiation, it
produces complex molecules and I would not
be able to tell you, if I had seen that image
on the right, the fluorescent image, I would
not have been able to tell you is this the
Murchison material, or is this the synthesized
material.
They're really very similar in their properties.
So, that really gave us yet another answer.
So I'm gonna summarize now the first half
of my talk. This is what a dense molecular
cloud looks like. We call it an interstellar
dense molecular cloud because they're between
stars and they're dense rather than being
diffuse.
They're mostly made up of dust particles.
These are little silicate mineral dust particles,
micron-size range, and hydrogen. That's what
composes both. Star formation. That's where
stars are produced. And solar system. The
stars, early in their career, begin to make
hard UV radiation and that, then, is what
illuminates the dust particles and drives
the kind of chemistry I've just shown you.
So, let's show you a little summary of this.
There's that dust particle. It's about the
size of a bacterium, by the way, just a few
microns across. So, nothing but a silicate
mineral, olivine, pyroxene. These are ordinary
minerals. But it's spewed out by stars, supernova,
and nova when they explode.
The dust particles accumulate ice mantles.
The ice mantle begins with very simple compounds--water,
methanol, carbon monoxide, and ammonia. UV
radiation is the energy source that drives
a synthesis of all that stuff on the right-hand
side, including amino acids, ketones, amides,
quinones, and amphiphile.
And amphiphile is like a soap molecule. Those
then accrete in the early solar system, form
comets, planetesimals, bringing the =organic
stuff along. Those then accrete to form planets,
like our Earth, and deliver the trio to the
early Earth. But, but, one little problem.
The early Earth went through a collision with
a Mars-sized object. This melted the early
Earth. It volatilized all of the organic material
that might have been there and so we are left
again with the question, where did this stuff
come from? There must have been lots of stuff
delivered during this accretion of the early
Earth.
But here now, we've melted it to volcanic
temperatures that completely destroys all
organic material, so we have to think a little
bit further. And here's what we now think.
So, there's a molten moon forming from this
debris ring. There's the molten Earth.
The organic material has been vaporized. Sooner
or later, the Earth cools, oceans form, but
there's none of that original organic material.
So what we think is that comets and meteorites
and what we call interplanetary dust particles
that have organic material on them, all helped
produce these of this last accretionary process
that gave us a lot of the organics we need.
So, you can see the record of this in the
moon. Look at it through a telescope. You
see all the craters remaining from about three
point eight billion years ago. And you also--.
We know that the moon got hit, the Earth got
hit, and all of that stuff is delivering organic
material and water back to the early Earth
when this was happening.
By the way, the ocean is probably in the range
of ten percent comet-water. A lot of the water
in the ocean came out of the Earth's interior
during the volcanic outgassing at that time.
So that's, as I say, the first half of what
I want to tell you about. Just to drill this
in, this is a comet that we've seen recently.
We've had another probe go 'round the comet
in orbit. It's taken these beautiful pictures.
This is called a Temple1 comet. This is still
not the comet that we can see. It's pretty
far out in the solar system. When we analyze
comets, we see that they're about 60% percent
water ice, 30% percent mineral particles,
and ten percent10% organic compounds.
So, just imagine now these are delivering
water to the oceans on the early Earth. And
some of this organic stuff survives the impact
of delivery and would have been available
for this process. You don't get a sense of
how big comets are, but what I did here is
to put the skyline of Manhattan to give you--.
It's several kilometers in diameters. It's
what comets really look like when they go
past. And we're gonna see them again. OK?
OK, now let's go back to four billion years
ago and think about what the early Earth was
like. Here's an artist's version of the early
Earth.
And if you didn't know that was the early
Earth, you might think that that was one of
the islands of Hawaii, like the big island.
'Cause the early Earth was volcanic. A lot
of the land masses poking up through the salty
ocean were volcanic in nature. And so, we
have a nitrogen and carbon dioxide atmosphere.
The nitrogen was still around at that time--very
unreactive. The carbon dioxide was many-fold
greater than it is today. Most of that carbon
dioxide has now turned into limestone. But
back then, that was our atmosphere. No oxygen
to speak of. There is a lot of energy available.
Thermal energy, light energy. Salty ocean.
Because there were land masses, there would
be freshwater ponds by precipitation. There'd
be electrical discharge, yet another form
of energy. And that's what we had to work
with. In our minds, we say to ourselves, "That's
the early Earth."
Well, what can we do with that concept? Let's
think about what was needed back then to get
life started. Conceptually, pretty simple.
You needed some monomers that could form polymers.
We know that amino acids are in meteorites,
so we imagine that amino acids were being
sprinkled down, or synthesized, on the early
Earth.
We know that nucleobases like adenine are
in meteorites, so we imagine there might have
been ways for nucleobases to be delivered,
or synthesized. We know carbohydrates are
in meteorites. That's work with George Cooper,
just right up at NASA Ames.
And we know there must have been phosphate
there. So, we're sort of on the way. This
is what we imagine would necessarily be there.
Then, I say that there must have been amphiphiles
to produce these compartments that I've told
you is so important.
When I talk about self-assembly, I wanna make
sure that you understand what I mean by that.
Most of you probably know that DNA is a double-helix.
You can melt the double-helix, which is double-helix.
You can melt it into single chains just by
raising the temperature.
And it doesn't have to be very high, maybe
70, 80, 90 degrees, and you've melted the
double-helix. If you then cool it down, those
two single strands find each other. They wind
back up into the original double-helix. That
is a self-assembly process. Nothing makes
it happen.
It just happens because of the properties,
the chemical, physical properties of the nucleic
acids. When a protein is synthesized coming
off the ribosome, there's no folding. As it
comes off, it folds into a specific structure.
This is essential for life to occur. If that
folding were not very precise, we could not
be here.
That's another self-assembly. Finally what
I've shown you is the lipid self-assembly
into membranes. Well, I wanted to challenge
myself and my colleagues to think beyond the
laboratory. The question is I've shown you
self-assembly occurring under laboratory conditions
and I claim that it might happen on the early
Earth.
Is there any way I can go beyond just a hand-waving
claim? Well, I think what we have to do is
to try our experiments in a natural, prebiotic,
analog environment, such as Bumpass Hell.
Bumpass Hell is a few hours’ drive north
of here. It's a little volcanic outbreak on
Mount Lassen.
And it's amazing to visit. I recommend it.
It's about a mile hike in from the road, very
easy to get to. So, can you imagine life starting
up in something like this? Now, I'm gonna
claim that this is the kind of condition that
prevailed on the early Earth and the conditions
of such an environment are what would have
given rise to the polymerization processes
that finally gave rise to living cells.
Charles Darwin was thinking about the same
thing long ago. Here's a little note he put
in a letter to his friend, J. D. Hooker, in
1871. "But if and oh what a big if, we could
conceive some warm, little pond with all sorts
of ammonia and phosphoric salts, light, heat,
electricity present, that a protein compound
was chemically formed and ready to undergo
still more complex changes. At the present
day, such matter would be instantly devoured
or absorbed, which would not have been the
case before living creatures were formed."
So wasn't a prescient thought. This guy was
smart. He was looking ahead to what we're
doing right now, thinking about warm, little
ponds. I think about hot, little puddles,
thinking that something like proteins, a polymer,
could be formed. And, really, my hat's off
to Uncle Charlie for thinking that and writing
it down.
Here's what I think Charles Darwin's warm,
little pond might look now that we know more
about it. It would have been in a volcanic
setting, such as I showed you at Bumpass Hell.
Here's one in a very famous painting in the
basement of the Smithsonian, what the Earth
was like several billion years ago.
So, here's a warm, little pond of what we
know now. And I decided to go to Kamchatka.
The Bumpass Hell is right in the middle of
a lot of plant life and a lot of people tramping
by. I wanted to go to a sterile environment,
a still and analog environment. And such an
environment is in Kamchatka, Russia.
I've been there twice. The Kamchatka geothermal
regions I consider to be what we call primitive
Earth analog environments. High altitude,
high latitude, and volcanism produce sterile
sites for experimental tests. Can self-assembly
occur? This is what Kamchatka looks like.
If you go two thousand miles East, you're
in Anchorage, Alaska, which is where we fly
out of to get here. We landed at Petropavlovsk,
the little upper arrow there. We hop in a
Russian troop carrier and about five hours
later, we are delivered to Mount Mutnovski
Menovski, which is the little bottom arrow
there. Here's one of our trips.
Some of the people in the audience know some
of these people. Jan and Jake are well-known
astrobiologists now. They were post-doctoral
people at the Carnegie Institution of Washington.
Jamie [ ]Elsila, Megan Spencer were graduate
students right here at Stanford University
in Dick Zeder'sare's lab.
Jamie is now working astrobiological problems
at Goddard. Then we have Vladimir in the white
cap, white coat. He was our local organizer.
And clear to the right is Igor, who was our
guide for this trip. And clear to the left
is my buddy and neighbor, Tony Hoffman, who
is the photographer on this little field expedition.
Here we are climbing up.
It's about a two thousand foot climb from
this little hut we stayed in to the crater.
Here's Vladimir looking down into the crater
of Mount MenovskiMutnovski. When I think about
the primitive Earth, this is my vision of
it--sterile, nothing's there, very dilute
organic solution of stuff that might be there
from [ ]infall from synthesis.
Hot water, steaming volcanism all over the
place, and little ponds that we can use as
experiments. Here's a fumarole. And I reached
down in the fumarole just to test whether
any organic material was there, anything alive.
And I pulled out a flask full of mud. We took
this back to my lab here at Santa Cruz and
analyzed it.
And really, there was nothing there. We had
no indication of any organic material and
no indication for sure of anything alive.
So, this is a good place to do the experiment
I'm gonna show you.
So, I revised Darwin's conjecture and said
to myself, "But if, and oh what a big if,
we could conceive in some hot, little puddle
with all sorts of prebiotic amino acids and
nucleobases, lipids for membranes, phosphoric
salts, light, heat, electricity is present."
So that is really the experiment I'm gonna
tell you about. Here's the recipe. This is
what we're gonna put into a hot, little puddle.
Gotta have four amino acids. Four nucleobases.
One gram each. Phosphate. Glycerol. Myrisytic
acid. That's this thing here.
It's an amphiphilicampiphilic, soap-like molecule
that's our membrane-forming material. Then
we can just pull out samples every hour for
several days. And we're gonna ask whether
self-assembly can occur and whether any interesting
synthesis can happen. And here's what we found
out.
Let me just show you what it looks like. This
is Darwin's hot, little puddle. That's a boiling
area right in the center. That's about 97
degrees, 93 degrees at this altitude. And
this is clay down, this guy here. Here's the
clay is down there, so a lot of volcanism
produces clay.
And up there, we have fluctuating wet-dry
cycles. And keep that in mind. I think that's
really important 'cause at the edges of pools
like this, is sometimes gonna get wet, sometimes
gonna get dry. Wet-dry on an hourly basis,
daily basis. So this is a place where interesting
chemistry can occur.
And what we're gonna ask first though is can
self-assembly of membranes can occur? So here
I am pouring a primordial soup, prebiotic
soup, into Darwin's hot, little puddle. Notice
it's white. The reason it's white same reason
this is white. It's got membranes in it.
It's got the lipid, the myristic[murcytic]
acid. And what I want to show you now is the
same thing about an hour later. And with apologies
to Michelangelo and the Sistine Chapel, I
think that this is where life began.
[laughter]
So that white stuff that you see, the white
scum, is self-assembled membranes. So I'm
satisfied that I can make at least compartments
in a thing way outside the laboratory.
This is very comforting to me anyway. And
my colleagues think I'm a little bit crazy
for doing this sort of thing, but that's OK.
I'm at a point where I don't mind being a
little bit crazy. So here we are now with
this membranes. And what we wanna do now,
though, is to see if the membranes can do
any good in terms of polymerization.
So, that brings me to the last part of my
talk. So this shows you close-up what we know
membranes are produced by at the molecular
an electron level. Down at the bottom, you
see a phospholipid and a cholesterol. And
this is what is in the membranes of every
cell of your body.
A hundred trillion cells, every one of them
has a membrane around it, made out of those
two components. This is what the prebiotic
membranes are made out of. There's that fatty
acid, or soap, that I've been telling you
about. So this is what a lipid bilayer looks
like close-up.
This is a model from Andrew Pohorille Pohorille,
right here at NASA Ames, who does this kind
of modeling. And you can see that there is
an oily center. This is a cross-section through
the membrane. There's an oily center composed
of hydrocarbon chains, hydrophilic groups
on either side, in contact with water.
So, that's what a membrane looks like, the
lipid component. So keep that in mind because
you're gonna see that again as we go on. Last
point to make before I get to the molecular
biology is that a property of vesicles is
that when they fuse, they turn into a multilamellar
matrix--what we call a lipid matrix array.
And anything that is outside becomes trapped
between those layers. And you can see them
trapped, the little pink lines there. When
you rehydrate, you get the stuff back and
now it's inside the vesicles. Some of the
vesicles have stuff inside. To prove that
to you, there's an image of what we call freeze-fracture
electromicroscopy.
There's some vesicles on the left and you
can see they're about the size of bacteria--about
two microns. When you dry them they turn into
that dry multilamellar lipid phase. And that
is what we believe is able to trap. Anything
that's outside gets trapped between those
lipid lamellasr you see on the right.
To prove that to you, we put some DNA in with
some vesicles, put it through a single dry-down
ied-out, rehydration. All those bright fluorescent
is stained DNA inside the vesicles. It was
all outside to begin with. So this just demonstrates
how powerful it is.
That's through a single wet-dry cycle you
get these protocells. Same thing I just did
for you here. OK, now a little bit of biochemistry.
I'm gonna try to keep it as simple as I can
for those of you who haven't had biochemistry.
This is adenosine monophosphate. It's one
of the four monomers of DNA and also one of
the four monomers of RNA.
That's what it looks like. This blue and black
thing upper left is adenine. The black and
red thing in the middle is ribose. And the
little red and yellow thing is phosphate.
Adenosine monophosphate. That is one of the
sub-unit monomers of all nucleic acids.
So what we're gonna try to do is to get that
to polymerize under these conditions I've
been telling you about. Here's a cartoon of
what we think is happening. There's the lipid
bilayers I showed you. And look at that little
thin line. Those are all of the AMP molecules
that have been flattened out and organized
between the lipid lamellae.
And they're not just stuck there, by the way.
They're able to diffuse around because this
is a liquid crystal. This is not solid. These
things are able to diffuse around in two dimensions.
So, here's what I claim. I claim that every
time two of those come together, there's a
chance for a water molecule to leave and produce
what is called an ester bond.
That's what holds nucleic acids together.
Ester bonds. Very simple. You have a water
molecule, make a chemical bond, and that if
you make it long enough, you make a DNA molecule,
or an RNA molecule. So the question is whether
this organization can help that process along.
Just another view of it. There it is up on
top, I should show you a solid glass where
you just dry the AMP down without any liquid
present. It becomes a solid, glassy phase.
It can't react because everything's stuck
in place. There's no diffusion. But if we
do the same thing and organize it in a lipid
matrix, what can happen is that water can
leave and stuff can polymerize.
So that's the idea. If there are any organic
chemists in the audience, this would be of
interest to you, almost to nobody else. This
is that mechanism that I told you for ester
bond formation. Basically, we're reversing
hydrolysis. In hydrolysis of RNA, water is
added to the ester bonds and you break it
down to the mononucleotides.
And all we're doing is setting downup conditions
where water can leave the mononucleotides
and produce RNA. Very simple. This is called
Fischer esterification, discovered a hundred
years ago by a very famous German organic
chemist. There's a bunch of little resonance
structures.
The main thing is here at the bottom, you
got an ester bond. Water leaves and you can
make an ester linkage. Does it work? The answer
is yes it does. In 2008, we published this
paper and in it we showed that if you dried
outdown vesicles with monomers and cycle it
up to seven cycles--wet-dry cycles--and at
elevated temperature, 85 degrees C, under
these conditions you can make RNA molecules.
Notice that upper left you can see cycles.
One. Three. Five. Six. Seven. Each cycle produces
more and more of this stuff. And by the way,
those black, that black stuff is radioactive
label. We've attached that to the end of these
RNA molecules with a little enzymatic step
that you see off to the right.
RNA in yellow at the top. Those enzymes had
a radioactive phosphate shows up in these
gels that we can use to separate the product.
And notice also, what we call a ladder. At
ten, twenty, thirty, forty, fifty, one hundred.
Those are known links of RNA.
And if you look up at the hundred and bring
your eye across, some of those molecules we
made are way up in the hundred range. This
is really long. Plenty long enough to make
a ribozyme, for instance. So, everything else
you see there is individual experiments, very
reproducible.
We just varied the conditions. And it's not
very interesting except to say that it's a
robust reaction and it works. Here's the last
stuff I wanna tell you about. Just a few more
slides. How did replication begin on the early
Earth? No one knows. We just don't have a
way to think about this yet.
But I think we have a lead into this. Maybe
replication can occur under the same conditions
that I've talked about. So, we tried this
out. And a paper was published earlier this
year. Paper by Felix Olasagasti, from the
Basque region of France. Kim and Pourmand.
I'm the only American citizen in that particular
team, which is very common in university science.
And look what we're claiming. Non-enzymatic
transfer of sequence information under plausible
prebiotic conditions. That is a big, scary
claim. Until somebody repeats that, I don't
want you to take this seriously.
We're the only people that have done this
so far. We're hoping that other labs will
pay attention and repeat it. If you're interested,
it came out in Biochiemie, 2010, very late
in the year. Here's the idea. If you have
a solution of the four bases, A, G, T, and
C, those little colored squares, in the presence
of the template and if all you do is dry it
down, you get a glassy solid.
Not much can happen because it just dries
out. The stuff cannot diffuse around. It cannot
line up by what we call Watson-Crick base-pairing.
But, if you dry it in the presence of lipid,
the stuff can move around and it has enough
time to find the complementary base-pairing
between the yellow and blue, which is A and
T, and the red and green, which is the G and
the C.
You can see them all lined up there. And then,
because these conditions allow ester bond
formation to occur, you zip up all of those
ester bonds and you end up with a double-stranded
DNA that has transferred the sequence from
the template to the product strand.
So, here's the formula for doing this. My
little recipe. Pretty simple. We're just simulating
a fluctuating environment such as I've shown
you. We mix the DNA template about a 55mer.
That means its got 55 nucleotides. We know
the sequence. It's got four nucleotides. A,
T, G, and C.
We have phospholipid vesicles. That's the
stuff that's gonna form that multilamellar
matrix. Gonna dry it down under carbon dioxide.
Oxygen tends to inhibit this. Gonna give it
about two hours at 85 degrees. We're gonna
add water, dry and heat again, repeat five
times.
Then see if there's any double-stranded DNA.
If we're right, we should see double-stranded
DNA there. Furthermore, if we see it and ligate
the products together, sequence the products,
and see whether any information is transferred
from the template to the product strand.
And that's what we did. That last bit, by
the way, is very high-tech molecular biology.
And I won't have time to go into it. Then
we gotta compare and we use bioinformatics
techniques to compare the base sequence to
the expected sequence. DNA is synthesized.
See that thing there that says complete system?
This is a fluorescence assay for double-stranded
DNA when you have the complete system, you
get double-stranded DNA out of it as indicated
by this fluorescent dye. We then took the
material and put it onto a gel.
We did electrophoresis. And see that little,
clear to the right, 50 base pairs? That is
in the range of our template. And you can
see that we have a double-stranded DNA showing
up in the gel in that 50 base pair region.
So we're pretty sure now that we've not only
made double-stranded, but that we can separate
it.
So, we've isolated that double-stranded material,
ligated it, did a sequence analysis, and finally
compared alignment scores. If all we had made
is random fragments of DNA, it would've shown
up on the left side of these alignment scores,
where there's virtually no alignment at all.
As the alignment score increases, that means
that we have sequenced information transferred.
So, all of that product that you see there
is our product sequence. And those are big
alignment scores. They're up at the point
where we have only about a ten percent error
in transfer of information of these thinbetween
strands.
So, that is the main thing you should take
away from this. We know that adding lipid
gives sufficient complexity to allow RNA synthesis.
They become ordered within that array that
I showed you. And the DNA template is present.
We can get sequence information transferred.
The next question is how do we get this system
to evolve? Nobody knows how to do that yet.
That's where we are. We've had a few steps,
though. Jack Szostak, my colleague back at
Harvard, is taking interest in this. He's
gotten a partial DNA to occur inside a fatty
acid vesicle under conditions where an activated
monomer can get across the membrane, add itself
to that partial DNA to complete the double-helix.
And then, those large vesicles can divide
into smaller vesicles. So, that's about where
we are now in the search for how life began
and how to simulate it in the laboratory.
Thanks for your attention.
[applause]